de ce côté le kremlin dénonce les
tentatives de l'otan je cite d'exploiter
le territoire ukrainien les précisions
avec notre correspondant à moscou en
triomphe comme prévu les deux
présidentes avant tout parler d'ukraine
vladimir poutine n'accepte pas que la
russie soit tenu pour responsable de
l'escaladé des tensions sur place et
pointe du doigt des provocations de kiev
et l'activité importante de l'otan à ses
frontières le président russe a
également demandé à son homologue
américain des garanties écrites
concernant deux mesures l'arrêt de
l'expansion de l'otan vers l'est et
l'arrêt du déploiement de systèmes
offensifs d'armement dans le voisinage
proche de la russie un conseiller de
vladimir poutine qui a suivi les
échanges a tenu à mettre en perspective
la position de la russie vis-à-vis de
l'ukraine en rappelant que moscou est
préoccupé que par sa propre sécurité
je transmets les paroles de poutine
selon mon interprétation mais elles sont
très importantes
poutine a déclaré
vous les américains être préoccupé par
nos bataillon sur le territoire russe
à des milliers de kilomètres des états
unis
alors que nous nous sommes vraiment
préoccupés par notre sécurité
par la sécurité de la russie dans un
sens global et à l'échelle mondiale
voilà comment poutine a commenté la
situation à la fin de la rencontre
faisant le bilan des échanges de vues
qui ont tué
les deux hommes ont évoqué d'autres
sujets comme l'iran la cyber sécurité ou
encore l'amélioration du fonctionnement
des ambassades respectives et de façon
plus générale joe biden et vladimir
poutine se sont dits conscients de leurs
responsabilités concernant la stabilité
et le maintien de la sécurité dans le
monde ainsi les contacts vont se
poursuivre entre groupes de travail des
deux pays sur tous les sujets abordés
six mois plus tôt lors du sommet de
genève